what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the room around up our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and opening
this episode up is something that never
needed to be a news article in the first
place but apparently it was ryan
reynolds was asked about deadpool 3
during an interview with variety with
his new movie and the answer was i'm
working on it
it's further along than the other x-men
movies but it'll come out at some point
and that's literally it i don't know why
that's a news article but a lot of
people have been asking me to talk about
that there's nothing to talk about here
there's no there's nothing to discuss
here ryan reynolds is just like is the
thing i'm working on and it'll it'll be
here when it's here yeah calm your
horses cool your jets home slice that
was basically ryan reynolds response
[Laughter]
so i don't really know
what all there is to report on this
whole thing but moving on to the
actually important stuff and this will
have a spoiler for the eternals film so
for those of you guys who don't want to
have it spoiled make sure you check the
time stamps down in the description and
skip ahead past this segment into the
next one so you can avoid spoilers
apparently the events of eternals are
going to tie into black panther 2
specifically name with a submariner now
i'm not really sure how you bridge this
gap here right because according to the
rumors that are out there the emergence
right so tiamou the dreaming celestial
starting to emerge from earth but
ultimately being stopped by the eternals
apparently that affected atlantis
whether it tore the entire kingdom apart
or cause massive damage or something
like that we don't really know what we
do know or at least what's being rumored
here is that the damage to atlantis is
basically being blamed on wakanda by
name or the submariner here's the
biggest issue with that there's nothing
to bridge this gap
there's nothing to indicate that that
wakanda would have anything to do with
this it seems like an arbitrary reason
for name of the submariner to basically
launch an attack against wakanda just
kind of a random plot device in order to
bridge the two of them if that's really
the case it's kind of disappointing but
it seems a little weird i could see them
saying that around the time that tiamou
the dreaming celestial was emerging that
wakandans were investigating what this
whole series of earthquakes happened to
be and they kind of came across atlantis
and so when tiamou was emerging and the
name of the submariner saw the wakandans
that he just associated the wakandans
with all this structural damage that was
being done and somebody thought it was
their fault that they were somehow
attacking atlantis or something along
those lines i could definitely see that
right just what does it affect a case of
mistaken identity but name with a
submariner having no idea what's going
on outside of a giant head and a giant
hand emerging from the inside of the
earth and saying it's got to be the
wakandans and then attacking them seems
weird to me right i don't know why it
just it seems like it would just be
neymar going out of his way right
because the kingdom of atlantis and the
comics is right smack dab in the middle
of the atlantic ocean right so you've
got like the us on one side and england
on the other and so it just seems to
make more sense to me that if name of
the submariner was going to lash out at
the surface world because of what was
going on with the emergence during the
events of eternals that he would attack
like an eastern coastal city in the
united states so like new york or
somewhere in virginia or like florida or
he would attack england or something
like that that he wouldn't go out of his
way
to wakanda
[Laughter]
to attack them right it just it seems
kind of weird that the only way to make
that work is again to have something
about the wakandans investigating
basically the area around atlantis
around the time the emergence happens
and that just leads to him believing
that wakandans are involved right so
having said that as we normally do with
our rumor roundup here let us transition
to our discussion on gaming before we
get into the real meat potatoes in this
episode we're just focusing on a marvel
and dc crossover so as the first talking
point in our gaming segment here
bethesda is doing what bethesda does
best which is basically just milking the
gaming community for all it's worth
basically doing this by way of skyrim
what are they doing here well what
bethesda is doing is apparently they are
releasing or re-releasing skyrim as a
10th anniversary edition called skyrim
anniversary edition do you guys remember
on the ps4 when they released skyrim
special edition again
milking the gaming community
but it'd allow you to download mods and
different things along those lines some
of which you had to pay for with this
it's not the case instead with the
anniversary edition you still kind of
have to pay for it but you don't have to
do a piecemeal instead if you bought
skyrim special edition the creation club
expansion is 20 bucks if you never
bought skyrim special edition you can
just buy the anniversary edition as a
standalone game and that'll cost you 50
bucks not really sure how i feel about
this i'm going to be honest with you
guys i'm kind of tired of seeing game
developers just milking the gaming
community i mean i understand why right
there's no reason for them to stop doing
this if they know people are going to
buy it and we know people are going to
buy it
they know people are going to buy it so
the only way to really keep things like
this from happening is to just not buy
them right for bethesda to release
skyrim 10th anniversary edition and it
just tanks right it's just like just the
sales are abysmal right because it's the
gaming community saying stop
re-releasing crap give us new stuff
right like give us elder scrolls six
it's the only way to make that point
until we do that they're just going to
keep rehashing the same old things like
rockstar just continually expanding on
grand theft auto online as opposed to
releasing gta 6. so having said that let
me know what you guys think down in the
comment section do you guys like this
idea does it kind of irritate you like
it does me let me know what you guys
think but moving on here i was totally
oblivious to this apparently final
fantasy 7 is getting a mobile game
called final fantasy vii the first
soldier it comes out on november 17th i
had no idea this was the case mobile
games are kind of a split thing for me
right i've played mobile games that are
just amazing and i've played mobile
games that are just kind of like you
know whatever this is one of those times
i might actually get it because i'm a
big fan of the final fantasy series
especially final fantasy vii that just
hits me straight into the nostalgia
feels right i was in like middle school
when i was in high school when that game
came out actually i was in high school
when final fantasy tactics came out god
you guys remember that game i don't
remember how old i was when final
fantasy 7 came out
i want to say i was in high school
regardless i loved that game it was a
great game i had a great time playing it
this seems kind of cool i might check it
out again i'm usually on the fence about
mobile games but i just kind of felt
like throwing that in here because i
didn't really realize that was a thing
so that's kind of cool the important
thing here is our next topic which is
that marvel's avengers is releasing the
great power event at the end of the
month which is going to add spider-man
it's going to add a new raid and it's
also going to add an adjustment to the
power cap which is kind of cool here's
one of the funny things about the the
marvel avengers game i played it when it
first came out but one of the things
that i learned after playing bungie's
destiny in destiny 2 is not to buy the
game when it first launches
instead wait like a year or two to
basically buy the game because then you
get all the expansions and stuff that
have been released up to that point
otherwise you're basically going to be
buying this bare bones game on launch
day and starving for content because
you're just gonna roll through the
expansions in the blink of an eye and
just be like okay and then you're gonna
be bored you're gonna be done right so
when i first got the avengers game when
it first launched i thought it was okay
had a few bugs so i actually kind of sat
it down i haven't picked it up since let
me know down in the comment section is
it worth picking back up again or should
i wait a little bit longer should i give
it a little more time i know they have
like the black panther expansion and
that kind of stuff now so let me know if
it's worth getting back into and if it
is then i'll fire it back up and start
playing it some more the biggest issue
you have with a great power event is we
don't really have any footage belonging
to spider-man regarding like his
movements or anything along those lines
so it's still very hush-hush i have to
believe a trailer is forthcoming here in
the next couple weeks if for no other
reason than to drum up hype for the
expansion it wouldn't make any sense to
launch the expansion with no marketing
behind it although games have done that
before and it turned out to be
disastrous because nobody knew what was
coming
so nobody bought it
but nonetheless it's one of those things
yeah let me know what you guys think
about about marvel avengers down in the
comments let me know if it's worth
playing again so having said that our
final bit of gaming news is actually a
really really disappointing one faraxis
has postponed the midnight sun's game
until late 2022 and i am so disappointed
by this i get the reception to it hasn't
been the most warm reception there ever
was when it came to a marvel game
specifically because this is really more
of a card style turn-based combat game
so if you're not a big fan of that this
game won't really resonate with you but
the roster looks cool right you get like
the midnight suns you get the x-men the
avengers the runaways which nobody cares
about but you do get a pretty cool
roster here and i'm pretty excited to
play this for those of you guys who
don't know fraxis is the company behind
the sid meier civilization games and the
x-com games now i never played x-com
just didn't really strike me when i saw
the trailer so i had no interest in it
but i do love the civilization games
they're they can be very very very very
slow so i'm really excited to see how
faraxis basically takes that model that
they're so used to building and applies
it to a game that you would expect to be
more fast paced it looks like a standard
fast-paced turn-based combat game but we
won't really know until it actually
comes out i'm looking forward to it i'm
just really disappointed that it got
delayed
but they said the reason for the delay
is because they wanted to polish it a
little bit more i mean what's what's the
counter to that right like hey guys we
had to delay uh the release of midnight
suns why well because we didn't want to
release some garbage well that's a
stupid reason i mean what are you gonna
say there right i mean
you can't be mad at a game developer for
postponing a game because they wanted to
polish it a little bit more although
some game developers do that right they
say like they're delaying the game
because they want to polish it a little
bit more and then the game they release
is still garbage and buggy as hell
isn't that right cd project written
do you know what i'm talking about
with your garbage cyberpunk game
but getting back into our comic book
movie news
[Laughter]
uh casey walsh who is well known for
dumping information out there leaks
different things along those lines he
was on the change my mind podcast
recently and it actually revealed
there's a big project in the works
regarding the x-men over at marvel
studios and disney he said he's still
digging around trying to find out how
credible this news is or this rumor is
whether or not there's any actual fact
to it but the rumors that are going
around is that marvel studios and disney
plus are hunting for basically musicians
and the reason why is because they're
working on the theme
for the show
that they're gonna bring back which is
actually in the animated series
now here's the thing even with the
rumors that we have there's scarce
little information out there regarding
how this project might unfold whether
it's a total reboot or whether it's a
continuation of the series and if they
do do a continuation of the series just
pretend like season five never existed
and just pick up from season four and in
fact don't even pick up from all of
season four just pick up from like
beyond good and evil right like just
after that just pretend like everything
for the second half of season four and
all of season five didn't exist and just
call it a day but we don't really know
what form this project is going to take
so at the end of the day this is one of
the things to contend with it could feel
totally different from the original
x-men the animated series or it could
feel exactly like it but regardless if
it is true and they are reworking x-men
the animated series regardless of what
form it takes i'm going to watch it i'm
going to give it a shot now i'm going to
tell you right now
if i don't like the show
i'm going to say something
i'm not going to be like well i mean you
know it's a show that exists i'm going
to be like this show is garbage either
that or like you'll see me come on here
and i'll be like this show is amazing
you're gonna see it one way or the other
i will absolutely talk about this but
this is the first that i'm hearing of
any credible information out there about
disney and marvel studios reworking
x-men the animated series so i will be
keeping my eye on this
very
very closely because i am very
very excited about this but our next bit
here actually comes from kind of a
cryptic tweet from dan slott and the
reason why is because disney plus day is
coming up pretty soon and one of the
things that he was talking about here is
that apparently as far as the rumors are
concerned that she hulk has basically
finished filming that is essentially a
done show and our first trailer for the
show could be released on disney plus
day whether or not that happens is
anybody's guess in all honesty i'm
excited for she-hulk i'm not the biggest
fan of she-hulk in the comics but that's
why i'm even more excited for the show
because i'm curious to see how they
adapt the character from the comics
she-hulk didn't really have a lot of
memorable moments in the comics she did
during the events of avengers
disassembled where she just went like
full rampage and actually right now in
marvel comics in the avengers stories
they're doing world war she-hulk which
is okay but it's got some cool moments
right it's got some cool aspects some
cool segments here so i'm kind of
curious to see where this goes and what
they end up doing with it regardless i'm
looking forward to it so let me know
down in the comments section are you
guys hyped for she-hulk are you kind of
like
i don't know is this whatever but
getting into our final bit of news here
which is something that we had to talk
about as soon as i saw it apparently
during the filming of their newest movie
when it was the rock and gal gadot and
ryan reynolds that the rock turned
around to the two of them and said we
should make a marvel and dc crossover
film like we should make that happen now
i'm gonna be honest with you guys if
anybody could make that happen it would
be the rock because the rock's just
popular enough right i mean the rock's
level of popularity is almost on a whole
different planet right like he's the
most followed person on instagram it's
crazy how popular this guy is and i know
i'm excited for the black adam movie and
i feel like if dwayne johnson was able
to make a good enough pitch to dc and to
marvel to bridge that gap and get them
to make a movie that has the two of them
crossing over it could be done not only
that apparently it's been teased for
quite some time and it kind of makes
sense i mean we do have the references
in the eternals right like the constant
references to like batman alfred
superman it's really the most on the
nose stuff that we've gotten from the
mcu where they're just like yeah man
superman exists i mean i'm kind of
surprised it took this long right like
it's superman and batman you'd have to
leave the planet earth to find an
organism out there that doesn't know who
batman and superman are
they're just that popular but if you
guys who read comics recall the doomsday
clock event from dc comics there was a
point where jeff johns actually had
references and was teasing the idea of a
marvel and dc crossover and while we
expected that to be a comic crossover
that seemingly never came to fruition i
think it'd be amazing if it happened in
the form of a marvel and dc film
crossover the biggest issue that you
have here though is i feel like the
roster is not really big enough if i see
a marvel and dc crossover i want to see
a big roster now that's me as a comic
book fan talking as the average
moviegoer the roster's perfect it's just
enough people to keep track of and it's
not so many people that you would be
confused about who's who and get lost in
the movie because i have to believe if
marvel and dc made a crossover film it'd
be a one shot right it'd be one movie
it's not gonna be like the comics where
it's like a four issue series right it's
not gonna be like a four film series
instead it would just be like one single
film and i think it'd be cool right it's
high time marvel and dc did a crossover
they haven't done one for almost 20
years so it makes sense that we would
get one coming up soon but having said
that i didn't know exactly how it would
look i mean the closest you have to
superman right now in the marvel
cinematic universe is essentially icarus
but if i'm going to see an analog of
superman in the marvel cinematic
universe face off against the actual
superman from the dc film universe i
want to see the sentry or i want to see
blue marvel preferably lou marvel
because i think that would be cool
although he would probably just get
absolutely thrashed by superman the
closest competitor to superman truth to
tell is hyperion he stands the best
possible chance right marcus milton from
earth13034 that guy was basically a copy
of superman from dc comics in marvel
comics of course the closer version that
you got from that was a sun god from the
great society during avengers and new
avengers but outside of him who you only
saw for a handful of issues and then
basically was killed by a giant monster
that doctor strange summoned to their
universe that hyperion is the closest
you get from a consistently appearing
character in marvel comics to the
superman concept in dc comics so i would
love to see hyperion in the mcu and then
have him face off against superman in
the dc eu so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section right
would you guys be excited to see a
marvel and dc film cross over i think
it'd be awesome and let's be a little
honest with ourselves right like
marvel studios crossing over with the dc
film universe could be just what dc
needs to save itself
because it's bad with that being said
guys this room around up and really no
video on this channel is ever complete
without us taking a jab
at the dc film universe i do it with
love
i jab them with love in all in all
reality i do and the reason why is
because their movies just aren't that
great and it's disappointing because
they were the original creators of
superheroes but that's a discussion for
a different time we're gonna go ahead
and wrap this episode up thank you guys
for watching we will catch you all later
peace